few countries perhaps no country does
this sort of thing better
such pageantry performed with such
precision and this year of course
matters more than most
the royals came in their carriages the
duchess of cornwall and the duchess of
cambridge with her children and a new
generation learning the ways of the
royal family
[Applause]
[Music]
significantly for the first time in 70
years at trooping the color the soldiers
were marching without the queen watching
on prince charles his son and air prince
william and princess anne conducting
duties for her his royal highness the
prince of wales dressed
in the uniform
of
colonel the welsh guards
and
wearing the green sash of the order of
the thistle
and the collar which is like a chain
over his shoulders
of the order of the garter followed by
the duke of cambridge kind of the irish
guards
and the princess royal they will salute
the color
as they pass
in respect
of its importance
the annual trooping the color has marked
the official birthday of the british
monarch for over 260 years
the first battalion irish guards and
more than 1200 officers and soldiers
from the household division in a display
of military pageantry on horse guards
parade together with hundreds of army
musicians
of cambridge looking on his perfect
vantage there
[Music]
to the traditional tune the british
grenadiers the escort for the color
moves forward
and it will turn to face directly the
color that it has the privilege of both
guarding and trooping later on meanwhile
the mass bands do the spin wheel
one of the most extraordinary movements
on parade every single soldier has a
different set of instructions in order
to adjust the band's position by 90
degrees and still have it in the right
position to lead the rest of the parade
and although it looks like they'll bump
into each other
they just don't
and the pipes again for helen laddy as
the scots guards
march past in quick time
that is the time i've marched into
buckingham palace
as
an
to that tune and all the soldiers march
that little bit taller
[Music]
joanna what struck you about what we've
watched unfold over the last hour or so
it's the usual thing i mean it's just
extraordinary to see british ceremony at
its very very best and being the
daughter of a soldier i'm always
terribly proud to see the military out
absolutely can you think how hard it is
to ride a horse and play a musical
instrument and stay in line and follow
orders i can't do any of those
so all of them together it's like you
know it's like one of those it's just
sensational and there's such a huge buzz
of affection from everybody here but
every time the the um the
you know god save the queen is played
everybody stands up everybody's craning
their necks hoping to see them
[Music]
after the military march the people's
march young and old families from across
the uk and the world all united in this
unique tribute to a unique queen
and with his mother's role curtailed it
was prince charles out and about shaking
hands
and the queen has come onto the balcony
with the duke of kent
many people have camped out for days to
bear witness to this moment in history
and today the sun shone for them and the
queen who appeared on her balcony
alongside her cousin the duke of kent
[Applause]
along the mall the multitudes came
together at the palace gates to say
their thank yous to the only monarch the
vast majority of them have ever known
and as they did so the king's troop
royal horse artillery fired an 82 gun
salute
[Applause]
it was the cue for the queen to reappear
this time with more of the family in tow
the working royals as they like to put
it
[Applause]
pride of place in the front prince
george princess charlotte and prince
louis stealing the show in the nicest
way with his facial expressions and
within moments looking skyward and a fly
pass to remember
and overcomes the first wave
wave two which is one british army
wildcat with three british army apaches
seventy aircraft flying down the mall in
waves
among them the familiar sight and sound
of the lancaster bomber the spitfires
and the hurricanes perhaps one of the
greatest sites of all from the battle of
britain flight coming towards us now and
for the queen and her generation as they
see this great lancaster bomber flanked
by three spitfires and two hurricanes
what a great sight
look at them flying over now
the raw listen to it brings back
memories of 1939-45
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wave 12 is four hawks
attack aircraft
i think young louie's find that quite
noisy
and here we are at 7-0
wave 13 15 typhoon making the mark of
the queen's 70 years a sovereign
[Applause]
[Music]
and here they come the red arrows in red
white and blue filling the sky with the
great salute of the three national
colors
the queen platinum jubilee commander in
chief
this was a balcony picture with more
than a nod to the future of the monarchy
noticeably no andrew who's announced he
has covered and only the smallest
glimpse of megan and harry
where there is pomp and royal ceremony
and cameras are plenty there is
sometimes protest and so it was today
animal rebellion claimed they were
responsible and said they were demanding
that royal land is reclaimed
they got the attention they wanted
from the police at least
make no mistake this was a day of joyful
celebration of a queen still very much
in control and apart from her mobility
issues seemingly in pretty robust health
[Applause]
and if jubilees are a thank you from the
nation
then this one is special
very special
70 years and counting
this country is likely never to see
anything like this again
mark austin sky news buckingham palace
you